So you think DeVoe and his wife are super villains. Who are you really. I was born on the same evening you were
I know every answer to every question ever asked
Incredible !
Clifford !
The body is deteriorating
faster than the chair can handle. It'll survive long enough
I'm being framed for something that I didn't do he stood among us like wolf in sheep's clothing. This is the only way. Tell everyone
You're the flash
If every one knew my secret we would never be able to stop running. Happy holidays everyone
There's a whole bunch of DCTV that just dropped so I figured I'd do a video
I know a lot of you been requesting young justice so that's also part of this too -
there's also a new round of the flash ring giveaway all you have to do to enter just be a
Subscriber and leave a DC related comment on the video, so we'll start with the flash stuff, then I'll talk about Legion of super-heroes
Brainiac introduction then I'll talk about Batman Beyond on Young Justice
We got a little more information about how the trial of the flash is gonna play out because like the trailer lets you know he tries
To be the flash while this is going on and it totally doesn't work
We know he trades the flash costume for that prison jumpsuit in iron Heights
So he can't be the flash and be sitting in prison at the same time without breaking the law
Sure, he could phase right through the wall
No, big deal, but he'd have to blur his face continually to keep cameras and people from recognizing him
But the synopsis for the episode teases that Iris and Joe must decide how far they're willing to go to keep Barry out of prison
meaning that Joe is
Probably going to cross the line like he was ready to kill Devoe sitting in his chair in his house as an intruder if it
Meant rescuing Barry so earlier this season they teased the idea of Joe crossing the line you may remember me talking about that before episode
7 because that was when they laid all the cards on the table
Before that the producers had teased that Joe would have his own battle with a thinker that would be different from Barry so Barry has
a little more of a literal fight like he fights the villains each season
Joe versus the thinker is more of him being backed into a corner where he's willing to
Doctor evidence to get Barry off because they can't do it the legit way
But I don't think that they're gonna turn Joe into a criminal just to get Barry off
So they'll take him right to that line. He'll probably struggle with that idea, but let me know in the comments
How crazy do you think that Joe is going to go trying to protect Cecile and his future baby along with his other child Barry?
But I think we're all just wondering when Cecile's baby is going to become relevant to the thinker story arc because right now
It's like you have all this thinker stuff going on the trial of the flash Barry's been framed
And then you've also have Cecile who's pregnant with a baby
She has been in no way threatened by the thinker he hasn't made any comments to Joe that lets us know that he knows
Cecile is pregnant so right now. Those are like two completely unrelated things by the end of the season they had to bring those together
We're gonna need more diapers
The big thing with legion of super-heroes a lot of you may have started watching
Supergirl since they started teasing this storyline maybe you're not watching, but you're just curious about the Legion
People are dying
I have to wake up
What's happening in the next episode of Supergirl is that they're introducing Brainiac 5 which is a pretty big deal?
They did a version of him play by James Marsters on Smallville
He's gonna help rescue Supergirl who Reign beat into a coma in the midseason finale
So if you didn't see it Supergirl got her ass beat, so that's why they need to roll Brainiac out so presumably
He'll be on for the rest of the season and he might wind up being a love interest
Because this is what the actor looks like and love triangles are kind of the thing that they do on Supergirl
So we'll see who the next Legion character. They introduced after Brainiac is but right now. They already have three including Mon El
They haven't said what his backstory is going to be on the TV show because at various times
They've retcon things so originally he was descended from
Brainiac 2 - so Brainiac was sort of like his grandfather in a sense
But then later more recently as the new 52 he's more of a clone of Brainiac 1 the evil version of Brainiac
So we the way he winds up working with the Legion of super-heroes he has super intellect and that he's sort of a human calculator
Compared to the other people of the 31st century remember that funny reverse-flash line where he says in the future
I'm a genius. How smart do you think that makes me here?
It's the same thing for Brainiac 5, but he develops this special computer called computo
They might work up to that on the TV show
but he also creates a time sphere that he uses for time travel that might be how they wind up getting the Legion back to
The future when they eventually leave Supergirl because I don't think they're gonna stay on the show for forever
But whatever they end up doing I'll do an easter egg video for it so no worries so getting into Batman Beyond
I know you're all wondering about Young Justice season 3 stuff. When's it going to drop?
When are we going to see a trailer the producers have been very active on social media?
Answering fans questions and also teasing them like oh you know
Maybe we're gonna do this so people are asking about
Characters that they might be able to do in the future the question of Terry McGinnis, Batman Beyond came up like would he cameo
Way ahead of you !
Batmobile !
Ignition
Sorry pal, but you're history
Who sent that thing it didn't say whoever it was they didn't stop at one
Seven against two pretty bad odds
For them
And the producers were like yeah
we could totally do that you just have to watch and see you have to support the show so if you are wondering how to
Do that here's the deal it's on the DC streaming service
They haven't said how much that's gonna cost
It's basically DC's version of Netflix like
Disney has their own streaming service that are developing that they're gonna put all the Marvel all the Disney all the Pixar stuff on
So everybody has their own version of that, but they haven't released a lot of information about when it's coming out
It'll probably be cheaper than Netflix
And it's gonna have Titans so like you sign up for you pay that monthly fee you get a bunch of new shows
Including a new Harley Quinn animated show, but beyond that they didn't clarify if they were gonna do Terry McGinnis
How they would incorporate him because he's from the future
So they'd have to be some sort of time-travel involved for Batman Beyond to be Batman
During the events of Young Justice season 3 or season 4
Tadaa!
So just stay tuned for that they'll probably release a teaser or at least an animatic in the next couple of months
They said they haven't finished animating any of the episodes yet
But remember it takes about a year to get animation out so they probably recorded most of the dialogue with the actors
there are 26 episodes total so what I'm expecting is is that they'll either launch the series in the summer or
sometime in the fall
But I'm expecting it around the summer because that's when a lot of animated series drop just because most of their target audience will be
on break from school
So they'll have the free time to support the show so just let me know in the comments below
Which other characters beyond Terry McGinnis?
Do you want them to bring on to Young Justice season 3 beyond the ones that they've already announced and there are a ton of
Characters since it's the holidays be sure to leave all your requests for bonus videos in the comments below
But congratulations to the giveaway winner from my last video Robert Ricardo. Please private message me so I can get your contact details
I'll name a new winner when I post new flash
Click here for all my Wally West Titans Easter eggs and because it's Stan Lee's birthday click here to watch
Every single one of his movie cameos. Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight